before getting started I wanted to give
a brief overview of why I believe that
data science is key to oberus future and
this is really a combination of three
factors coming together firstly that we
are a real-time business that secondly
is operating across the globe and
thirdly we want to of course incorporate
nuances of the various different
marketplaces as well as product
preferences of our end-users and in
order to do this efficiently and
effectively there's really no other way
than to leverage data science at scale
and so unsurprisingly uber has heavily
invested in data science from early
stages on in the company and now we have
hundreds of data scientists working
across the entire company to improve
user experiences so given the importance
of data science to the company as well
as the large number of people who are
working in this space we're continuously
seeking to increase the innovation cycle
and speed in this field whilst improving
accuracies of the various different data
science models and so today I'm going to
showcase to you how we accomplished
faster and more accurate data science
results at the beginning our data team
has heavily invested in building tools
and platforms that empower us data
scientists and data analysts but we
didn't stop there as a next step we
wanted to empower everyone within the
company and transform them add a push of
about an inter data scientist of course
with best practices and guardrails
incorporated and to this end we hired
data science specialists for example in
the areas of conversational AI
experimentation anomaly detection and
many different other fields and together
with their cross-functional counterparts
and engineering product and design these
teams build scalable tools and platforms
that transform anyone at uber into a
data scientist now let's start out by
looking at the for us lifecycle stages
of a typical data science
it starts off with data exploration
followed by iterative prototyping once
an adequate model has been found it then
gets productionize and of course during
rollout as well as post rollout we want
to carefully monitor any of these
algorithms now this closes the first
generation loop of any data science
project and there one can start anew if
necessary so the goal here is of course
to speed up every one of these four
steps of the project lifecycle so let me
show you some of the platforms and tools
that our data team has built in order to
accelerate this let's start with the
exploratory phase data really is at the
center of everything because without
data there is no science and so in order
to transform the hundreds of petabytes
of data quickly and efficiently from
data into knowledge our data team has
built various different tools around
this including a data book that surfaces
and manages a meta information about the
data on the right-hand side you can see
Kepler GL as you can imagine at uber we
have a vast number of spatiotemporal use
cases that we're tackling and so of
course we want to visualize this data
efficiently and very quickly and to this
end our data visualization tool has
built this data agnostic highly
performant web based application that
can help us visualize very large
spatiotemporal datasets at scale we have
also open sourced kepler GL about a year
ago where it has found a lot of
followers we have now over 35,000 uber
external users of kepler GL and it has
gathered over 5,500 github stars now
when it comes to the development phase
or prototyping phase our data team has
built what is known as data science
workbench think of this like an iPad or
notebook plus plus that is deeply
integrated into our data stack allows
for version control share capabilities
within the organization and also most
recently has been deeply integrated in
to our machine learning platform
Michelangelo to allow for fast
deployment of machine learning models on
the right hand side you can see her
Avadh this is ubers open source
distributed deep learning framework for
tensorflow
which has at the time broken new ground
in training speeds for deep learning
models when it comes to production
ization uber has heavily invested in a
deep learning as well as machine
learning platform called Michelangelo
this allows us to utilize off-the-shelf
algorithms as well as these days also
allows for us steada scientists to
deploy any Python code in a sandbox
environment when it comes to monitoring
this is attacks that often both data
scientists and developers are less
excited about to this end we have built
a fully automated real-time anomaly
detection stack that I'm going to touch
on a bit later as well as an
experimentation platform that allows for
experimentation set up at scale now of
course these tools and platforms have
very greatly empowered us data
scientists and analysts and have helped
speed up the innovation cycle but as
mentioning into in the introduction we
didn't want to stop there we wanted to
transform anyone in the company at a
push of about an inter data scientist of
course with best practices and
guardrails incorporated and this is
where the platform teams come into play
these are deep domain experts in
particular areas of data science such as
forecasting anomaly detection
conversational AI computer vision or
experimentation I call them our data
science ninjas and together with their
cross-functional counterparts these
teams build tools and platforms that
then others can leverage across the
company and this allows us to multiply
the expertise skill sets of these
individuals across the company so today
I want to tell you about three areas of
data science that we have
platform izing the first area is a the
forecasting platform here the vision of
the forecasting platform is to provide
highly accurate forecasts at a push of a
button without any forecasting expertise
required the only input needed by the
end-user is the historic data perhaps in
form of a query or a CSV file and a
forecast horizon as in how far the user
wants to forecast and we do everything
else
automatically underneath the hood I'm
gonna show you how the output of this as
you can see here on this example our
point forecasts as you can see in
turquoise as well as of course
prediction intervals to get a sense of
the uncertainty around the forecasts as
shown here in yellow and red
respectively these are very important to
make actionable and informed business
decisions so one of the things we look
at before we start platform izing is
three criteria the first one is will
this data science area if platform eyes
yield step function improvements to the
user experience the second thing is do
we have a large number of use cases
across the company that weren't the
investment in platform izing this data
science area and then thirdly across
these use cases are the modules that
we're going to be building highly
reusable and the answer to both the
forecasting platform as well as the
other two areas that we're platform
izing is a resounding yes here in this
slide I'm showing you three of the
wealth of forecasting use cases that we
have across the company on the far left
you see marketplace forecasts here we
are forecasting both supply and demand
related metrics at very fine granular
spatiotemporal fashion in the center you
can see real-time system outage
detection use cases the idea here is
that we want to figure out as quickly as
possible if there are any issues with
the uber app such as people not being
able to
sign in/sign up or perhaps not be able
to take a trip this is still an open
research question due to a couple of
factors firstly the sheer amount of
metrics we have over 500 million time
series secondly the real-time nature of
trying to detect such issues we want to
operate at four nine so 99.99% of
availability which gives us less than
one minute of downtime per week and
thirdly the high signal-to-noise ratio
that we require because these algorithms
will page potentially people in the
middle of the night and nobody wants to
be woken up just to find out that a
Justin Bieber concert just finished so
we have to have extremely high precision
and recall for these algorithms we were
able to break new ground in this field
and one of these systems that we have
developed is to build dynamic thresholds
like you can see in the center graph
here that very closely follow the time
series behavior the day and night cycles
the underlying growth as well as the
variability and for simplicity I've then
also added the data that came after the
fact in blue here into this graph as
well on the very right hand side you can
see the use case of hardware capacity
planning at uber we still have a lot of
hardware on premise and so for us it is
very import multiple months in advance
to know highly accurately how much
hardware to purchase as well as to
provision and this is particularly
important for high demand days such as
Halloween or New Year's Eve this is also
a very challenging problem given how
nascent our company is in terms of the
number of years that we've been
operating at because many of these days
are highly day of the week dependent and
so we might have not seen them yet
exactly under these circumstances again
here we were able to come up with
completely novel algorithms that have
broken new ground in terms of the
accuracy of describing such a special
event days and so therefore we are able
to
ensure that we're not over provisioning
hardware which at the scale that uber is
operating at would be fiscally
irresponsible and at the same time
ensuring that we're not under provision
which could yield to an outage and lost
trust of our writers and driver partners
so basically we need to have the
Goldilocks principle applied not too
much and not too little hardware so
let's look at some of the steps that we
have been tackling using our forecasting
platform the first step in every
forecasting problem is to do data
exploration and pre-processing now
pre-processing is an often overlooked
step in forecasting problems and can be
as important sometimes even more
important than finding the right model
architecture to this end we have built
modules that automatically can detect
and handle common pre-processing tasks
the next step is to identify which
forecasting message to choose from there
are three major classes on the left-hand
side you can see classical statistical
approaches such as ARIMA or hold winters
I've also included the less well-known
fetta method we found it to be very
applicable to our time series it is also
a computationally very fast method and
it has won the International forecasting
competition m3 on the right-hand side
you can see machine learning and deep
learning approaches that were recently
have entered the forecasters toolkit for
example we have found lots of success
with quantile regression forests the
cousin of the well-known random forest
as well as deep learning methodologies
such as LST m/s the third category that
is the most recent category that has
emerged are hybrid methods these are
combinations between the classical
statistical approaches on the left hand
side and deep learning approaches on the
right hand side and one of our team
members Slovaks mill has developed such
a novel hybrid approach and with this
approach has won the International
forecasting competition and for now in a
nutshell it is impossible to forecast
which of these methodologies will work
best for a given forecasting problem and
so it becomes important to scan over a
variety of different forecasting
approaches to find the best one or the
combination of the best forecasting
approaches and so I would like to talk a
little bit about back testing and the
various different back testing
methodologies that we have implemented
for in our forecasting stack here it is
important to note that chronological
order in forecasts matter and therefore
also impact testing and so what one
needs to do is take a specific series
within the time series and train over
that portion and then tests on the
subsequent data now keeping that in mind
there are two major approaches that I
want to cover on the left-hand side you
can see the so-called sliding window
approach here you have a fixed window
size of both training and test set and
as you move forward you drop more
historical data as is seen in the light
gray portion on the right hand side you
can see the expanding window approach as
the name suggests here the training
window size grows lag over lag whilst
the testing size typically stays
constant and this allows for great back
testing especially if the time series
data is short now at uber we have
developed parallel language extensible
back testing framework that has both of
these methodologies incorporated and
this now allows us to completely
automatically scan over a wealth of
different forecasting algorithms such as
the ones I've shown you on previous
slides and then to automatically surface
the most accurate forecast to our end
users of course with prediction
intervals to get a sense of uncertainty
here I'm showing a heat map this is
illustrative data that people can use to
dig more deeply into some of the results
if they wish and we can slice for
example by various different dimensions
that is such as cities and then compare
various different forecasting models to
them now these really cover
the basic steps of any forecasting
problem that we were able to send me
automate or fully automate now I want to
cover some more advanced capabilities of
this forecasting platform the first one
is being able to estimate the impact of
special events such as holidays weather
concerts and sporting events as you can
imagine these can have very large impact
on our supply and demand and other
business metrics and so in order to
enhance the user experience we want to
have highly accurate estimates of the
impact of such special events now the
classical statistical approaches that
I've shown you on previous slides we
find them to be typically not very
amenable to such problems either because
you cannot incorporate external factors
at all or if you can they typically do
not perform well so we have heavily
invested in both machine learning as
well as deep learning methodologies and
here on this slide you can see an
example of one of the architectures that
we have used the first thing I want to
call out in the spirit of automation is
the pre-training step which includes an
encoder decoder approach which allows us
to automatically extract various
different features within the time
series we then concatenate the learned
embedding with various different events
data such as weather concerts holidays
and other types of events and then pass
it through a prediction network in this
case a multi-layer perceptron in order
to yield the final forecast in case
you're interested in more details we've
also published a white paper on this
topic and the link can be found at the
bottom of this slide we have also
ensured very high quality assurance on
this platform the first thing is of
course the data that is flowing into the
platform as well as of course ensuring
that we maintain high quality for any
forecasts that we're distributing to our
internal end-use
we've also deeply integrated the
forecasting platform into our data and
infrastructure stack in order to allow
for forecasts programmatically at scale
the second example of data science
commoditization I would like to go into
is natural language and conversational
AI and I would like to use as a concrete
example here one-click chat which is a
recent product feature that we have
launched in order to showcase some of
the common aspects of conversational AI
problems so here in one-click chat the
purpose is to help connect writers and
driver partners during the pickup
experience in particular to provide
suggested replies to the user based on
incoming messages that they're getting
and you can see an example of this on
the far right hand side so let's look at
one-click chat in the framework of
natural language problem there are
really two major steps here the first
one is given an incoming message for
example from a writer we want to extract
the intent or topic of conversation
now once the intent is found we then
retrieve various different replies that
match this intent and surface it to the
end user for example in this case to the
driver partner where they can choose to
pick one of those for example now this
seems like a very straightforward
problem but looking at it in practice
there various different challenges that
we're faced with firstly these messages
are very short they also have
abbreviations misspellings and also
autocorrect is not our friend as you can
see from this real-world example at the
bottom here I'm Washington for you this
should clearly mean I'm waiting for you
so any method that we want to use here
should not involve frequency based
methods such as tf-idf but rather should
be able to capture the semantic meaning
of the various different texts that
we're getting and so here we've used
Google stock to vaca methodology in
combination with nearest
Labour's approaches and trained it on
anonymized uber data and we were very
excited to see that the example of I'm
Washington for you is actually correctly
classified then as I'm waiting for you
so as mentioned earlier when we platform
eyes we're always looking for a wealth
of applications across the company to
help improve the user experiences and so
again I would like to showcase to you a
couple of the use cases that we have in
this space in addition to the one-click
chat example that I've just walked you
through we also have been doing an alpha
launch around hands-free dispatch this
allows now for driver partners to accept
and reject trips using voice and also
the voice equivalent to one-click chat
that will allow driver partners to
freeform speak their responses to
incoming writer messages on the
right-hand side you can see our customer
care use case here we have built an
assistant that helps our customer
service representative with various
different tasks now of course the
customer service representative will
always have the final say here but the
natural language system helps understand
what the intents are can identify what
the issue types are that people are
writing in about can make suggestions
about which actions the customer service
representative might want to take and
then also provides recommendations on
which response templates the agents
wants to start off from when writing a
response to the end user we've seen over
eight point eight percent reduction in
average handle time and of course this
has also improved the user experience as
a result here a very high-level overview
of the platform that we have been
starting to build on this front as
mentioned the majority of natural
language conversational AI use cases
would have as a first step
intent identification to the topic of
conversation and this is done by the
same
dick parser many conversational AI
systems will have a back and forth
component which means we want to keep
track of the state of the system and
this is done by the dialog manager and
then finally of course we want to
convert back the semantic representation
into human understandable form and that
is done by the language generator now
the third and final example of data
science commoditization and
democratization I want to talk to you
about is the most recent endeavor that
we have been working on and that I'm
personally very excited about and that
is semi automating or fully automating
exploratory data analytics at scale so
I'm sure many of you are faced with
questions that you can see here on the
left-hand side at uber we're spending
hundreds of human hours every week
answering questions like these or coming
up with actionable business insights
wouldn't it be amazing if you had a
system that could automatically scan
through the data and answer such
questions we have started to build such
a system and our proof of concept looks
extremely promising here but then we
wanted to take it a step further what if
you didn't even have to ask the question
the first place what if we had an
algorithm that could scan through the
data surface interesting insights to
business analysts to our business
stakeholders who can then combine these
insights with their business acumen to
make actionable business decisions and
again here we have built a proof of
concept and we've gotten really positive
reviews from our internal users who have
told us that we have been able to find
various different insights that they
would not have come up with themselves
so this would potentially give us an
opportunity to scale data analytics and
to be less dependent on the number of
human hours that we can spend on this or
the number of hypotheses that we can
come up with at the final stage of my
presentation I would like to walk you
through our strategy of commoditizing
data science because building platforms
is a multi quarter
two-year initiative and so it is really
important for us to set our data
scientist and platform builders up for
success here the approach that we have
been taking is of three phases in the
first phase we embed specialist data
scientists into various different areas
of the business this allows us to get
very interesting insights about the
opportunities the pain points and that
can have informed design decisions on
the platform it also allows us to solve
use cases that are of great interest to
the business and to user experience
right there and then and to build strong
relationships that are trusting in
nature with our stakeholders now of
course this is not a scalable approach
and so we quickly go to building
workflows or various different recipes
that the broader data science community
can leverage for example a Python
notebook that is easily discoverable
that people can build off from and then
the final step is of course to build
these automated platforms that I
mentioned that make anyone at uber into
a data scientist and we do this by
strategically choosing various different
use cases that help augment the platform
and reuse various different components
of it in case you're interested in
learning more details about the work
that I've presented today or about other
areas that we have been commoditizing
across the company please check out our
uber engineering blog post and with this
I would like to thank you very much for
your attention
[Applause]